[Music]
I see Jessica the VIP concierge here in
Los Angeles who is you know she knows
she's a head-turner she knows she's very
very attractive I think she was
physically attracted to Cody then he
became more attractive when it became
head of household and started winning
things left and right and she kind of
like was with the prom king but the prom
king is kind of now like public enemy
number one because he showed himself to
be a traitor so as soon as he loses
power and as soon as he becomes someone
in the house that no one else wants to
talk to I think she might keep the peace
with him in the house but then if he
can't advance her she might be like
that's that's what the breaks cotton
sorry Cody that means you're gonna have
to pick a new replacement nominee
Christmas you got screwed take a seat
oh he overplayed he got too aggressive
he was feeling himself he was drunk with
power
he thought I'm running the show well
guess what
like you're running out of gas you used
up so much gas well now he's just like
puttering out he's put a huge target on
his back
slow and steady wins the race you know
you can't peek too soon and now no one
except Jessica is really on his side
[Music]